[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Today,
I'm meeting with Janice Wong
to talk about Android
for Work and how you can
get started with business apps.
So, Janice, you're PM
on Android for Work,
and I know we've spoken
about it a little bit,
but could you tell
me a bit more.
What really is Android
for Work all about?
JANICE WONG: Not
only are we putting
a lot of the great
features, part of Android,
on the framework
side, but it's also
unleashing the capabilities
of our partners,
whether it's our
OEMs, carriers, or we
call them enterprise
mobility management partners.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JANICE WONG: But you
think about this.
Traditionally, Android
is very consumer focused.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
JANICE WONG: But we
want to really unleash
this for the workplace so that
people can bring their Android
devices to work and
be just as productive.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
It's a win-win, right,
because you get to use the
cooler consumer-oriented device
in the workplace, and
the workplace doesn't
have to provide devices to
workers, or maybe they do,
but if you bring
your own device,
then you can choose
what you use, right?
JANICE WONG: Yeah.
So we really want to
give all our users
choice, whether you're
at work or not at work.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now
what kind of scenarios
are there for different types of
apps or different form factors
or something like that in
the workplace, because I
know there's lots of different
ways that it can be used.
What have you encountered?
JANICE WONG: We call them BYOD--
Bring Your Own Device to work,
so that mean you don't
have to carry two phones.
You don't have to worry
about carrying a work
phone and a personal phone.
And then there are other ones
we call corporate liables,
so the company issues a phone
for a specific use case.
But then there's
also another kind,
which I find very interesting.
We think about it
as the kiosk mode.
It is single use,
usually tablets,
or you can think about when
you go to a cashier nowadays,
it could be a tablet
in front of you.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, yeah.
JANICE WONG: You pay, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right
or at a hotel, right?
Like a digital
concierge-type thing.
JANICE WONG: Exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
JANICE WONG: All
need to be managed.
And we have to make
sure we optimize it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, so that just
can't be any old tablet there.
That has to have whatever it
is that the corporate log in
and the corporate security,
all that type of thing.
JANICE WONG: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So how
does that get managed
and what are we doing in
Android for Work to help that?
JANICE WONG: So we work
with our EMM partners--
our mobility
management partners.
They are in the world of
managing all these devices,
but we provide the
framework, the OS,
to make it even easier for them.
For example, the
kiosk situation.
You don't want one
of your customers
be in the middle of check
in and then suddenly they
have to take an update.
LAURENCE MORONEY: [LAUGHING]
JANICE WONG: Right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
JANICE WONG: So
IT can say, OK, I
want to do this at 3:00
AM for all my devices.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
JANICE WONG: To provide a
really cohesive experience
but also manage it
in a secure way.
You get updates.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
Now, switching
gears for a second.
Developers.
Obviously, there are things
that developers need to know
and developers need to learn
to be able to take advantage
of the work that you're doing.
So where can developers
go to learn about what
they need for Android for Work?
JANICE WONG: I think a great
place to start is to go
to developer.android.com/work
where they can learn a lot
about the use cases and examples
that other developers have done
already and also testing tools.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh, cool.
JANICE WONG: But
honestly, just think
about developing on Android,
because you give the user
a lot of choice, different form
factors, phones, tablets, price
points.
You can even think larger,
like digital signage.
It all can be managed.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So if I want to start
writing some enterprise code,
I know where to go.
JANICE WONG: Sounds good.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thank you so much, Janice.
This has been a blast,
and I've learned a lot.
I really appreciate it.
JANICE WONG: Yeah.
Thank you for having me.